recién graduado pero todavía luchando
por encontrar trabajo San jean-lang se
especializó en transporte marítimo pero
después de la graduación sigue sin
empleo
me presenté a más de 70 puestos de
trabajo pero solo me llamaron dos o tres
meses para entrevistarme
una gran compañía naviera de tanteo
incluso antes de graduarse ahora esa
oferta ha quedado suspendida hasta nuevo
aviso ya que es otro de los sectores que
supere los impactos de la política del
cero
siempre creí que mi carrera estaba
resuelta pero este año debido a la
pandemia Hay demasiadas incertidumbres
ahora mismo no sé qué me deparará el
futuro
casi el 20% de los menores de 24 años no
encuentran trabajo en China la tasa más
alta desde que Beijing empezó a llevar
registros y ello a pesar de las palabras
de aliento del presidente chillimping
los jóvenes de China viviendo de una
época extraordinaria disponen de un
escenario inéditamente amplio para
desplegar todo su talento
algunos jóvenes ya no creen en las
perspectivas y están rechazando una vida
dedicada a la productividad y a los
resultados en las redes sociales los
entusiastas comparten sus experiencias
un término viral para esto es el Tank o
acostarse hace 4 meses estoy tumbada y
tú cuánto llevas en el paro me siento
como si me hubiera abandonado del mundo
Así que estoy tumbada todos los días
debido a la mala situación económica
algunos han tenido que cambiar de
trabajo funny solía ser agente
inmobiliario ahora es vendedor ambulante
cada vez es más difícil ganarse la vida
Los sueldos no son tan altos como antes
las primas son menores además en
Shanghai el alquiler y el costo de vida
son muy altos
una crisis de desempleo sin final a la
vista según las previsiones de este año
china registrar a su menor tasa de
crecimiento en cuatro décadas